can we check out the blame you're  wearing so you also like in your  especially you talked about dating a lot  so I just want to know like what kind of  woman do you look for it just for  everyone out there maybe like no one's  like I like older women older women they  just got it together if you got a chain  on the back your glasses I'm coming at  you  [Laughter]  [Applause]  I would have a drink with you just had a  birthday right yeah what is it like  getting older what do you what do you  thinking oh no it's just we're getting  older I kept thinking someone's on my  for my eyes for the longest well my  eyebrows that grew all the way I can't  see I've never shaved my eyebrows and  trim them down but now I have to I know  it's like this I will not stop talking  until you subscribe to my YouTube  channel that's right and I could talk a  lot seriously not gonna stop yep still  here not going anywhere I see you don't  walk away from this